To me, developing games
Is like breathing
The sun, the air, water, and games
The hunger I had when I was young, wanting to accomplish something
It’s a strong desire like breathing and life instincts
Developing games on my own sounds quite lonely
But that’s not true at all
Developing a game by myself allows me to
Work together with international composers or voice talents
Then we can showcase our product to players from all over the world
Like the previous game I developed, which was
Installed 5 million times on Google Play
And received 16,000 reviews
I love electronic music
And some geometric styles
After adding some mathematics and physics into the mix
Like “Magnetized”, for example
It has that retro style plus a bit of triptunes
Then you have “Beat Stomper”, which is a modern EDM
“Push & Pop” is like returning to the 80s electronic music
With the addition of a 2.5D visual style
Even though all three titles might sound similar to each other
But actually, this is what’s most fun about developing games
You need to use limited resources
To explore unlimited possibilities
When I was young, my younger brother and I
Loved to go play all types of arcade games on the streets
My favorite type of game was the spaceship shooting game
We’ve been searching for this type of exciting shooting games for a long time
Eventually, my two brothers and I decided to develop a game on our own
This is also why our workshop is called “Uwan”
At the beginning, I developed games by using the JAVA programming language
At that time, there were no global platforms available
So I was only able to market my games domestically
Later on, we launched our very first mobile game
“Lightning Fighter 2”
The game was downloaded over a million times after launch
And through Google Play’s Store listing experiments
The installation rate for “Lightning Fighter 2” was increased to 91% in Indonesia
Aside from “Lightning Fighter 2”
We also designed a strategic shooter called “Lightning Rangers”
A game like “Lightning Rangers” requires more server-related technologies
So we decided to use Google Cloud, which was a huge help in terms of game development
We also used Google Play Alpha Beta test features
To help us obtain numerical feedback from players before the product is launched
As well as to enhance the quality of our game
Actually, game development is to touch every player’s heart through hope
It is our biggest goal
The idea behind OPUS comes from exploration and stories
Every Saturday night, we hope players can
Experience the touching stories by exploring our games
It’s like having the experience of reading a great novel
With a back-end service such as the Google Game Services
We can update our games more quickly
In order to present the best parts of our games to everyone
Therefore, in terms of ARPU and conversion rate, our OPUS Earth Project
Have increased by more than 200% in a very short amount of time
To someone like me, who is an independent game developer
It is a huge help